there's no doubt in my mind that
Deadpool 3 is going to be one of 2024's
biggest movie releases considering we
have Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
sharing the screen as their most iconic
roles Deadpool and Wolverine how could
we not get excited we've got adorable
dog pool plushies hitting the shelves
and rumors that a certain major pop star
might be joining the MCU crew Yes you
heard me the infamous Hugh Jackman is
going to be putting on the costume of
one of his most iconic roles to date
Wolverine for what seems like the very
last time hey Hugh you want to play
Wolverine one more
time yeah sure right director Shawn Levy
is really leaning into that he calls
this situation two major movie stars
playing their most iconic roles on the
same screen together director Heaven
this one is much more of a two-hander
than either Deadpool movie has been I
know what you're thinking but what about
Logan this reveal had a lot of fans
confused because it's been pretty much
accepted that we wouldn't be getting any
more Wolverine after the 2017 film Logan
uh takes place in 2029 totally separate
thing Logan died and Logan not touching
that Ryan Reynolds and Sean Levy made
sure Deadpool 3 storyline takes place
before any of the lore from Logan so
lucky for us we get to see Wolverine
again there are also a ton of other
notable Stars joining Hugh and Ryan on
screen Emma Corin is supposed to be
playing the film main antagonist and
Matthew mcfadin was confirmed to be
joining the cast in March of 2023 he's
gained a lot of Fame for his role in
succession so I'm curious how he'll F in
the MCU two other stars are also
confirmed to be returning Morena bararan
and Stefan kichic who play Vanessa and
Colossus in the series marinaa spoke
with Screen Rant back in December 20123
a little bit about Vanessa and Wade's
relationship she said no matter what it
seems they always come back back to one
another there's a lot to look forward to
here to everyone's surprise Disney
revealed that Deadpool 3 was going to be
released 4 months earlier than its
original premiere date it was first
announced that it would be released in
September of 2024 then it was pushed
back to November and then finally all
the way back up to May 4th if you've got
whiplash so do I then in July of 2023
Deadpool had to stop production after 35
days because of the wga and sag after
just strikes we were exactly halfway
through filming Deadpool and then we
stopped obviously that did deter the
momentum of production thus putting the
premier date up in the air thankfully
though both strikes came to an end so
Deadpool could resume production and of
course change its release date one more
time to July 26th 2024 Ryan Reynolds
graced us all with the confirmation that
dogpool the very adorable dog Persona of
Deadpool will be joining him in the film
there have been a few behind the scenes
pictures of the now Infamous dog pool
running around the internet and they
definitely did not disappoint also I
have some great news if you're a plushy
fan you might be able to get your hands
on a dog pool of your own I'm not sure
how long it's going to take though
because apparently in true Deadpool
fashion she's been causing the Disney
plushy Department major nightmares Ryan
Reynolds and sha Ley co-wrote and
produced Deadpool 3 together and there
was a specific tactic to balancing
Wolverine and Deadpool on screen at one
time Ryan is amazing at wanting Deadpool
to lose Ryan is incredibly self-aware
and the character he plays yes Deadpool
is awesome and hilarious but he's also
deeply flawed and well Wolverine is
Wolverine Ryan operates from a place of
what's going to be most satisfying to
the story there was never a battle of
egos Ryan never viewed the writing
process as him having to fight for equal
screen time in the face of Wolverine so
will probably be seeing a lot of
Deadpool struggling to keep up with him
at times listen this hasn't been
confirmed but I definitely thought it
was worth discussing some casting rumors
are circling around on the internet that
Taylor Swift might be stepping into her
MCU era so I'm just going to go with the
very cliche no comment on all things
casting like I said it is currently just
an internet rumor but Sean Levy did give
us a cheeky little comment about it a
lot of the internet rumors are
completely false but some of them aren't
fans are speculating that she could be
portraying the role of the dazzler after
she was spotted with Ryan Reynolds Blake
Lively Shan Levy and Hugh Jackman at an
NFL game though she could just be
hanging out with her very specific
friend group that also happens to be
behind the Deadpool 3 film or maybe not
what are your thoughts on this swifties
bring all your Easter eggs and leave a
comment below Deadpool 3 is going to be
like nothing we've ever seen before with
Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds running
the show the most adorable four-legged
companion at their sides and a potential
appearance from Taylor Swift there's
hardly anything else we could really ask
for what do you think about Deadpool and
Wolverine sharing the big screen
together leave a comment and let me know